oh god what is that I love vegetables
they're okay
I crave meat and sugar I love vegetables
actually have a tattooed on my body I
like vegetables too but I don't have a
tattoo I really want to like them
because I want to be one of those people
who's like health but I'm not is this
squash Oh smells vaguely of farts like
all vegetables it's a raw potato this
has got to be some sort of a yam this is
delicious it tastes very much like
cauliflower is it squash nope this might
be a squash I honestly have no idea what
this is oh so this is what a rutabaga is
not neutered I love that word never had
a rutabaga we I know it exactly what
this is you can like make pie out of it
smells like it's nice hmm
oh oh you took a big bite oh god it's
sour it's like a natural Sour Patch Kid
it's rhubarb race one two three rhubarb
this is supposed to be made with pie
what is this this one is a yam it
reminds me of home I have no idea what
this is is this taro swallow it's not
taro what's taro root mmm that's why I
knew it oh my god this is taro I said
that and then I said it wasn't it's a
kind of carrot it looks like ginger it
smells like a dink okay I just got
chills all over my body when I smell
this tastes like ginger too it has some
kind of other flavor oh god I'm scared
don't be scared yeah wait wait is it oh
[ __ ] it's horseradish it tastes exactly
like wasabi no look son horseradish
oh that makes sense
ah what is this
I don't understand why you're so
affected by this bland white triangle I
feel like this is a yam he's like
crunchy water
it's like the earth uh oh that's like
really Pleasant ah this is jicama isn't
it it took him on the other word for
watercress watercress jicama that sounds
like a Pokemon pick him up attack I
think this has brought me closer to my
love for GMO this is confirmed my love
of vegetables sure I'll eat them but I'm
not gonna be like nah rutabaga why am i
limiting myself there's so many
different vegetables out there expand
your horizons